Here's something nobody warns you about.
The better you get at life, the worse
you feel about your progress. Your brain
is running a continuous software update
in the background, constantly raising
the bar on what feels normal. This is
called baseline shift phenomenon. Think
about driving. Remember when parking
required your full concentration? Now
you're probably texting while reversing
into a spot. Your brain didn't announce
this upgrade. Here's your proof. The 6
months ago test. Think about a challenge
you faced six months ago. Something that
stressed you out or felt overwhelming.
Notice how you're handling similar
situations now. That's not luck. That's
measurable progress your brain forgot to
celebrate. You're walking around with
skills you don't think you have. When
someone asks for advice, you probably
don't feel qualified, but you gave great
advice anyway. Your expertise has become
invisible because it feels normal to
you. But expertise doesn't feel like
expertise from the inside. It feels like
common sense. The truth is, you're doing
better than you think, and there's
scientific proof. Watch the full video
to discover the other hidden signs of
your progress that you've been
completely missing.